and the next talk is by antonia she will
talk about civil analyze she will
analyze the attractiveness since through
Twitter so please give him give her a
Warner a warm applause so all yours hey
so I'm Antonia taurus and I work at a
research a joint research institute of
the university of the Balearic Islands
and the National Research Council and as
you know the logos are going to be there
and I'm going to present a word with it
with Hassan colleagues not just mean so
they are here leash Maxim Runa and Horsa
well why did we do that and what it will
so we've in the Institute we there's a
group related to something social stuff
paralyzing morality basically human
mobility and when dealing with different
sources of data but we've discovered
discover a bad way compare some
different kinds of data such as Twitter
and a phone calls data we compare them
and the coral in big cities and the
correlation was bigger than 0.9 so
really good and that moment term we
started working more on on Twitter okay
we discover things like Spanish people
tweet on the roads I don't know we while
driving or the other ones in the cars
but they if we plot the tweets in Spain
we see perfectly
highways why we don't know the same
happens in Turkey but it doesn't happen
in Germany or France we are different
than know but well as scientist not me
my mortician that they're supposed to do
some make some questions and to find
some answers and well we are working on
Twitter tweets do you know what we tweet
is most of much people thin letter
treaties 140 characters with just one
user when you can do a retweet make like
or star or favorite or wherever it's
called now but when you see of course
it's never what you get this is a one
this is not complete with this is half a
tweet this is the information of the
tweet not of the user here you see the
first line you can read the text of the
Twitter 140 characters then we have some
information on the source which kind of
gadget did the two it came from in this
case is Twitter from Android then we
have some coordinates if that we did you
locate it if not as in this case is no
we have sometimes town we have some more
information lots of lots of information
well let's do it but if you had to read
this tweet was a retweet in in the
sender ql there could be the initial to
it so we would be twice long ok on the
right you can see the place if the user
has your location activated enabled and
when when you try to post a photo and
decide to market to take it at a place
you can do something like that and
places that's kind of big JSON data but
you also have user data all this is the
information of your user so 140
characters is more or less to kilobytes
of data it's characters okay so we need
to gather data do now I sit this date
together you we've been doing that since
2012 so long time ago and how do we do
that so we have to download the data
from Twitter to our database you know in
our case we decided to use MongoDB
that's an example how to do it just
listener you open wait what you get your
your keys you open the listener you
connect to Twitter to the API not the
usual API they have a special streaming
API where you connect you open a
connection and you receive and a small
amount of tweets okay in our case we are
interested in very study mobility so you
are interested in locations we are just
retrieving the tweets with geolocation
we can get both tweets with latitude and
longitude and do it with place these
latest ones we discard them and we just
use the latitude longitude yes more
accurate then of course we have to
strike the data from MongoDB okay I'm
quite sure you you know how it works is
very easy and now we can start analyzing
the analysis is not specially complex we
just started that just playing around
with the tweets to start finding some
information to go on and continue the
studies for a couple of years okay yes
some initial initial information so we
decided to select a 58 cities all over
the world the ones highly populated of
course but the the other condition was
they also had to be active on Twitter as
as you can understand there's no cities
in Africa cuz Tweety's has not a lot of
is there in China there's Beijing even
not they use Weibo would they also use
Twitter and we noticed we had lots of
information there these are the cities
and we structed the data from our
database well we defined the what we
understand power for city you know it
city has its own dimensions its own sake
kind of buildings once I bigger than
slams one spice high densely cubed and
we decided to homogenize and use radius
of 50 kilometers around the town hall
inside that most of the cities had the
damn hole in the center so it could be a
good start point then we gathered the
tweets in that 58 cities and the tweets
posted by the users like head tweets in
that city's okay we didn't collect any
special tree we didn't follow that users
we just retrieve the data we had already
store for four years okay we hand
Helen downloaded the user's timeline
uses status now from that we had not a
large amount of data we had more than 20
million tweets and half a million uses
what we get the starter in that and this
data it was collected in three years
more or less 1000 days we plotted it
because you know maybe the data we get
is something different and well it is
partially spirited as people and get
enough so we could start doing things so
they are scientists they do not do
rocket science but they ask questions so
they started asking where do we go well
do you go after visiting a city do all
the visitors of the city travel to the
same places later or not and for that we
instructed the data we and we did some
some videos I'm going to show you what
we are in Madrid so i'm going to show
you the one in madrid wait here you have
the the zero time of all the users was
the first tweet in the city in this case
the first the first bitumen read from
that we can the time when you see ten
days it's ten days after the first wait
for you to see have different times
times but we normalized it to the same
as you can see people that want visiting
Madrid went basically
at the beginning to spain netherlands
britain most of the dates are in europe
japan you have the years and after three
years you know people basically go to
Europe few people go to the states and
some of them go to South America because
fine let's compare it with another one
for example New York as you see as we
would expect basically these people from
the States but also from Europe it's
quite different from the one in Madrid
smoke global split from everywhere it's
not a him up but we can strut know how
it works particular point here there's a
lot of points they're here South America
I particularly was expecting to have
more people visiting South America and
Madrid and not New York and South
America let us lie lays like that
well not that I'll show you this one in
Moscow Moscow is Bay has a different
behavior very few people in the state's
basically in Russia South America snack
covered but you know Russia is almost
covered wait go for it again Russia
Europe not the Spain so Russian people
don't come here we don't go there no do
you see different behaviors comparing
different cities yes so inside it
they're scientists so they define things
they define two measures the coverage is
neither is this one it is to explain is
we divide the world in cells and the
coverage is the number of cells covered
by a twit okay the number of says that
there's at least one to it in it so the
cells visit after visiting City the
normalized radius well we define the
radius as the distance travelled by
Twitter users since they first Street it
in a city but you know if we compare
cities in Australia Diaz separated is
distant from every are no basis we are
going to have some bias so we normalized
by the people by the distance
residents cells in the average and which
kind of cities do you think are going to
be the most covered by these measures
European states European who was for
European body South Korea could be
basically there are the same cities
using both measures strange to know
since I like that but you see Rome Paris
and Lisbon since that most of the people
go to these this series then we see in
one place san francisco and the other
Beijing Hong Kong engine guy you know
from the fourth place down there's some
diversity but the three first ones are
the same okay and two vrai inhabitant
residents and tourists behave the same
way maybe this has to do with that there
are more people risen in heightened in
Rome then New York not possible but we
know that when we travel when we are
tourists we visit Amal more places that
we live in and so when we live in city
when we live someplace we go from home
to work and then to the barn the
restaurant but don't do very large
movements okay but when we are to list
we visit when we are in a country with
different regions we get that if we find
the radius as as a function of coverage
we have two different clusters local and
non-local basically we know that
not little people tourists visit more
cells cover more places in the world
than local people's we don't really know
the explanation the real explination the
actual solution of that it could be a
mixture between a lot of people doesn't
move that much and do it basically on
their place of residence and when we
travel we don't treat in the other the
other cities but maybe it's real that we
then move them match in that serious if
we if we super the differentiated
coverage for local and non-local you see
the three cities before are not here
well by the coverage this least one in
Paris with Moscow Emma scope is the
first one for Rocco you see Moscow
Beijing and st. Petersburg are big
cities in big countries and maybe the
local people there is also traveling
around the country and not to other
places this is a very easy analysis of
the data not much data and we discover
things that weren't spected to be like
that but then they have had equation so
we asked where do we go where do we come
from people that visit the city do they
come from the same places it's a
machinist not its variety we find
another measure this case is the
coverage the coverage we define it like
the number of distinct cells of
residents defining the residents as the
cell in which more than thirty percent
of the
of that user are located okay that case
we have almost the same ranking ok we
have from-- what's the first one before
we have Paris and Lisbon has moved a
little bit what does that mean it means
that Rome is visited from a lot of
cities lot of places different places so
smooth global then for example Shanghai
and New York people from different place
more different places with Rome Paris on
barcelona by the way you noticed Madrid
is not there sorry for that and then New
York we couldn't respect that you know
that's some starting analysis we are
still working on that and then we decide
wraps everybody loves graphs we decided
looking for communities in the in the
different user within the different uses
do we move European people travel in the
same way as American some people from
the states and south america we defined
the the relation as the fraction of
users that position see that this is it
also the other city and the strength of
the connections defines some kind of
communities we used a software well open
source software called awesome tool at
not in Python and sibley it's in C and
let's go was respected European people
travel to Europe and basically European
people go to the states New York San
Francisco to coast but we don't really
visit Mexico or Japan and Japanese
people prowl around Japan but they don't
move really much even not we were
expecting that they they will be moving
quite a lot Chinese people Asian people
is moving in Asian see you have the
different countries and in this case
Australia is is correlated is connected
is in the same community as Asia but
Mexico is not connected to the states
and it's not connected to south america
it's an individual community and unique
community they're just one country
basically they visit the same country
per day do not move around the world
even that we know that Spaniards Spanish
people travel to the south america and
attitude and we should expect well more
things apart from that we decided to
same model as the same thing with twist
excites in this case we recovered 20
twisted side we decided to go for doing
two in Japan lots of tweets in Japan go
on we have to we needed to have some
things in Asia in China we decipher the
Forbidden City because was one of the
places in China where there was more so
more of the twists and you know when
Europe there are lots of tweets we
decided to
for London Tower felt our the most known
places in the States and we went four
times the square near a false we know
that most of the people that go to
change the squirrels who travel to new
era first we didn't go to for them for
the livin for the status we just use
times the square in in New York Grand
Canyon is it's very we just covered the
the main region of course and then went
basically to to machu picchu there
weren't a lot of Twister we tried with I
cannot remember the the place it's in
the middle of Australia's like a peacock
a plateau a frog through and in for ye
twisdom we collected for four years we
had I seen there were 80 users we
suppose that because in some of these
places for example Machu Picchu they we
had 200 300 uses but then if you most
sankyo meters away from Machu Picchu
there was a large coverage even that we
could we could distract some information
and well let some sort of things we have
it's not really like that but some
example we have the tweets CSV we have
the you ideas latitudes and longitudes
yes I have some more information but we
it's not attached here we also use the
delay times and then will you remember
we define the
the grid for the world as 100 square 100
kilometers squared and we find like that
with the minimum maximum right left and
then we define for each of these cells
but yes it is an IV they should be here
for itself we define the country because
in the case of the city we were just
checking the cells of residence or the
coverage in cells but in this case we
would like to know a little more get a
lot of information and countries from
that information we mixed it with
basically with fantastical tina's here
but I think after Kiko's tutorial
yesterday you know how to do it it's not
not difficult we we get the residences
for for each user we we get residents if
he well if she has enough tweets and you
know the residence this place where does
most of the thirty percent of it we try
with deep fifty percent twenty percent
ten percent was almost the same thing
and well I'm ensuring this like that
it's not computing like that it was some
sort of visual thing for each user where
we have a dictionary of uses it's
naturally curious it's a data frame a
geo pandas dataframe and we have for
each user ID we have the cells he has
visited and the number of tweets here he
has he has done in each in each cell as
well we have the number of tweets work
just complete
summing up the information there's some
some strike and basically for each tweet
we get the user ID we get the cell the
tweet is located in and we increment
just just some kind of nice elevators
it's quite easy you know doing very easy
quite as the things we can you can get
some some astonishing things and then
for each user this basically is computed
with an apply in a data frame for you
1904 for each for each user we complete
the residence app for that we discovered
that people that visit takma how you
know placed in India covers I'm not
gonna say out the word with mustard were
people from all over the world travel to
India to visit time aha okay the density
of tweets in every kind country is very
well but you know almost everywhere no
or tamaha knees and visit them aha and
they treat of course there's much more
people than visit and I Holland why that
tweet singularities no one in China next
to it when no one there not a lot of
people spend more people in the States
some people South Africa I sorry yeah in
South Africa's through and and in Brazil
jam dinner is that lindex okay and this
one is an italian completely the true
there was there was a strata we
we were getting all the users that we
did in that place and then we randomly
attracted two hundred uses and checked
their residences their countries and
then we compared with we're trying to
have felt traveled to know how many
people how many uses did we have to do
to get the same information you know to
use the minimum data possible to to get
information and that Daddy we mention
could be trustful we notice that
strutting 550 uses we had basically the
same information and Stratton two
hundred users three hundred users that
was good because in as i said in some
places and machu picchu for example we
have very few uses so noticing that in
the other place is a small random
struction was good enough to to compare
my wood was making us quite sure that
things done with with places with few
tweets and a few user were good enough
you know in people listed in tomahawk
yeah in the state's this the second
country at the third and we compared
with the other one the other way around
people visiting Grand Canyon for example
come on people from the state or to rank
an EML to other people don't go there
well go throwing down to it it's always
the same thing but people from from the
states basically move through states the
the plot for the four times the square
was quite similar people from the state
visited Times Square but people from
Europe there was not such such such
people that they treat their time
visited there such a strange thing we
then within that to be released we are
in fat getting in in depth on that
because it seems to be an interesting
thing it was just a first approach to
humanity through worldwide human Model T
through Twitter and in that case we also
had a ranking you know in the other one
a Rome Paris and Lisbon were the first
ones in this case we have we don't have
cities we have teristic sides monuments
but we expecting to have more or less
the same kind of of Franken in the case
we covered radius we used radius
coverage and courage by country and we
notice that in in 12 3 with somehow the
the most visited with radius well radius
the normalized time it is ok not really
not the real race and the other one was
visit our even that in this case Grand
Canyon is in the second one encouraged
when we when we check the coverage by
country it's not there we've seen why
all the people that we see not only be
must of the people that visit Grand
Canyon is from the states so states are
a lot of
cells but just one country that's that's
why it's going that piece at our it's
there just in radius you know one on
Tower Times Square not as cover it as as
respect it to be and you know where we
are still working on it and now the
results are not very deep we are just
starting on that but we are going to go
on on this studying a little bit unless
in and further further things and that's
it
so Weston's fallen Tanya thanks for the
talk I was wondering if it would be
possible you were planning on releasing
the data set and releasing it and we
cannot you cannot we cannot because
Twitter's allows every one of you can
can open a condition to tutor and get
some data but then you cannot share that
data with the other people I have to try
sorry for that no questions as the the
twitter api is very limited how do you
handle that limits to to have this data
well it's limited twitter has basically
to AP is the stream api and the one the
rest of the regular queries api we are
using the stream one the one that has
very strict measures and that is the the
usual api the one that you crave for
statuses of for description not
description with information of the user
tan lines or friends followers like that
the other one you used open a connection
and Twitter sends you the data later
they think will be good and what we are
playing a little bit with is because if
you open a connection string connection
with with no limitations with with no
specific requirements you get its
setting people says that you get one
percent of the data gave it all the data
we but we just focus on delegated data
that
less than ten percent of all Twitter so
we get the percentage that we have is
it's bigger enough to to get that did
you consider the issue of retreat
because in some studies i saw these
issues about giving a different way to
our tweet yeah in fact for that we
haven't used to tweets but now we are
you are using retweets we are using
mentions between users we are going set
and you was just some kind of
preliminary word and how it was and we
are going diplomate thank you for your
talk what is the percentage of tweets
that are using the coordinates features
and are you thinking in some kind of
algorithm to guess the location of the
rest okay the about the percentage we
cannot know we have to trust Twitter
that we know that when when we get we
have no restrictions with do locations
more or less than sign years ago they
changed their policy one year ago before
that change we had ten twelve percent of
them words you located now much less
maybe five four percent the other
question is yeah okay we what can be
structed third easily is the place of
residence without knowing any and
any coordinates you can more or less get
the place of residence and in fact we we
were splitting to start working in the
on the on the one guessing visually
relocation we are basically is used the
language and the connections of the user
but the state of the art is it's not
very good and well as mogu we are
starting on that don't worry so any
other question con que criterias
establecido tsinghua tequila metros de
radio porque con que criterio con que
criterio pues esta nota la puedo
responder seguro por que no fue y OU
langue caja de esto pero vas a comment a
mere Erin la la dia de las Palacio
neighs mess disperses yeliz mess mess
compact ha's yaarana un punto medio que
sin cuenta que lo metros más o menos
podia Anglo bar gunas yo tras la la
parte centro segurisimo aparte de las no
dear a masseur vioz pero parte de la
so thank speaker again